how did you manage to stay
sane during the stress of dealing with
somebody chronically ill especially when
you have somebody who is on a loved one
who's on hospice you want to spend every
moment with that person but i knew that
if i didn't carve out time for self-care
that i wouldn't have made it to the
other side and my life at that point had
been incredibly stressful i mean there
was like obviously what my mother was
going through but there was infighting
in my family about her treatment it was
so stressful but every day i went to the
gym and i was sauna almost every day
cold plunge almost every day there's
such a bounty of evidence now showing us
that exercise is a tonic for mental
health even clinical cases of severe
depression and anxiety eating healthy i
think is a huge part of it as well for
any caregivers listening anybody who's
doing anything stressful i mean you've
got to make time for it don't start to
judge yourself or your situation until
you've had a workout and then reassessed